what movie are you making actually right
after this interview so once we're
finished I'm gonna be driving to Agoura
Hills where I will be directing my
second feature it's a film called stay
with me it's a drama and it's a story
about a woman who's suffering from
mental illness and it's about her best
friend and her boyfriend and how they
deal with the lead-up to and the
aftermath of her suicide so it's a it's
heavy subject matter it's not a heavy
film although there are some certainly
emotional moments in it
I met the the writer the co-writer of
the film was an intern of mine when I
worked at Cal State Northridge and he
was just dead set on making an
independent film once he graduated and
he bugged me for about six months and
eventually I joined him on the journey
and he said we can shoot in my parents
house you know I can get equipment for
free we can work with students that are
graduating from CSUN film program and
eventually I came around on it and we
decided to put the the team together and
I hired a group of actors that had
graduated from Chapman University's
acting program so those are all of our
actors we had like I said our crew is
all CSUN film graduates and a couple
Chapman students that I used to work
with and we're halfway done we it's a 13
days shoot and we finished day seven
yesterday so I'm on my way out there to
work on day eight today and we'll have
it done by next Monday and then we're
gonna go in a post and I'm hoping by the
middle of next year you know what we'll
have the film done so having made rising
start in Connecticut and different time
different state different world probably
what same things are you taking with you
or leaving behind set up set of skills
or you know expectations there's no
expectations on this movie
when we made rising star that was the
most important thing I had done in my
life up to that point and I pressured
myself accordingly this time there's no
pressure one because we're making the
film for next to nothing our entire
budget it's gonna be under ten thousand
dollars so that's a big part of it
that's a big help but also you know this
is not this is not something that I'm
looking at as a lynchpin in my life to
kind of carry me into another state of
being you know as a filmmaker I've
written and directed a feature already
so I know I can do it now it's just a
matter of how good can I do it so it's a
very different mindset on this one and
it's it's a very different process with
the actors I've find myself a lot more
collaborative on this as far as actors
getting input you know on their lines
and on the performance the crew members
that I'm working with them a lot more
collaborative with them this time
whereas with rising star I had a very
specific plan that I did everything I
could to stick to it's a lot different
now
and and honestly I like it a lot more
this this kind of collaborative approach
I think definitely helps and it starts
with with Adam Maimon my co-writer and
my producer he really is the energy
behind this film and I'm so I sort of
joined for the ride and that's something
I've never done before every other film
I've made it's always been my Genesis
and I sort of carry everything from
nothing and create everything from
nothing but now Adams really the driver
of this and I'm sort of along just to
kind of help Shepherd it through and
bring my network with me and bring my
connections and in my experience and
it's really been a great it's been a
great time so Adam came up with the idea
we met for pizza
last August almost a year ago this week
actually and he had an idea for a film
that takes place in two timelines that's
what he wanted to do
and I said okay well what are some of
the things that you want to talk about
what are the things that you want to
explore and he said you know I'm
interested in LGBTQ issues and how
20-somethings are dealing with identity
I want to talk about mental illness I
want to talk about grief and grief was
what stuck with me because my mother
passed away two years ago and that was
sort of like okay well why don't we
think of something that ties around the
death of someone close to someone else
and that was sort of the beginning of
the evolution of what ultimately the
story turned into so we we kept that
sort of two timeline idea the film takes
place in two separate timelines the
first one is the lead up to the young
woman taking her life and the other one
is the aftermath of it but the film cuts
back and forth between them so as to
give the impression that you know grief
is a never ending process and it sort of
permeates every part of your life so
that's that's kind of where we're at and
once we get into post-production we're
gonna we're gonna play a lot with you
know time and what you see and how
things are juxtaposed president versus
past and then stuff like that and I
think it's gonna be a good film you and
Adam you met for pizza and then how soon
did one of you begin writing taking
turns we we outline the film together
over about two weeks and then we split
up scenes to write I wrote most of the
timeline to stuff that happens after the
young woman takes her life because of my
experience dealing with the death of my
mom there were a lot of events that I
wanted to put in there that I had gone
through and in situations I had dealt
with and then Adam handled the first
timeline sort of the lead-up to it and
then once we combined everything we just
started tweaking together I would do a
pass he would do a pass then we did I
think eight tracks before we landed on
war shooting did you have a table read
with the actors or no no time for that
no we actually didn't even cast we had a
very interesting process for this our
other producer woman named Sarah DeLeon
she's also a talent manager and one of
her clients had read the script and
loved it and really wanted to be in it
so I said this arrow I'm happy to meet
with her you know we'll talk about it so
I met with her very smart young woman
her name is Laura Fox really had really
deep insights on the character of Katy
the woman who takes her life and really
connected with her and experiences that
she had had and when I met with her it
wasn't a casting session it was just
sort of almost like an interview and
when we were done I thought okay this
was the first moment where I sort of
jumped off the the regular path or the
path that I took on rising star where I
had to control everything I said I'm
gonna try something different on this
I'm gonna cast her not even seeing her
perform outside of her real and the
films that she had already worked on and
stuff like that I watched those was
impressed with her work I said okay I'm
gonna and I offer to the part and I said
listen I need your help can you find me
actors that you've worked with that fit
these parts that you have good chemistry
with and she ended up finding us the
other two leads in the film and we've
been working together and everything has
been flawless and I was terrified and
any director that you talked to would
probably look at me with a hairy eyeball
and say you're out of your mind for
doing it that way but when you're making
a film for this little money you can
take chances and you can try different
things so now I have three actors that
are a hundred percent dedicated to this
movie like incredibly dedicated they all
have an existing relationship so the
chemistry is already there it's not
something I had to create and now we're
off making this film how smart
looking at it now I you can say it was
it was a bit of a risk when we did it
but it's not just people she knows it's
the chemistry that that's where it's
really gonna show on screen you know
just because it could be someone from
acting class hey I want to get you but
to know that if she stopped seeing
scenes with them and they know each
other they've gone for coffee afterwards
whatever yeah that's gonna translate
they they were all friends so when we
did our first actual rehearsal by an
hour into it they're all hanging out on
the couch they're all lying across each
other's laps they're all laughing and
joking and telling stories they've all
worked with each other before two of
them were former roommates oh wow so it
was yeah it was one of those kismet
moments where you know all right we've
got three people you know it would take
ten years of work with me of casting to
try to find three people with this kind
of chemistry so really it really worked
you